people who
identify as trans exist people who make
the claim that they are a sex other than
what they were born at Birth exist those
people exist however the claims they are
making about reality are false that's
what we're saying we're denying their
claims
not their physical existence you [ __ ]
then the conversation moved on and got
more bizarre as we get to this exchange
between the doctor and a republican
lawmaker on the issue of whether
men can get pregnant
and you feel like you kind of know what
the answer is going to be but there's
there's one part of this answer that's
pretty interesting so I want you to
listen to this
Dr Kumar can biological men become
pregnant and give birth
um so men can have pregnancies
especially trans men so can biological
men become pregnant and give birth so
are you saying that a biological female
who identifies as a man and therefore
becomes pregnant is quote a man is that
what you're saying these questions about
who can become pregnant are really
missing the point I'm here to talk no no
no no no no this is me asking a question
and you answering I'm asking the
question sir not you right and I'm
answering the question somebody with a
uterus may have a capability of becoming
pregnant whether they're a woman or a
man that doesn't mean okay we're done
not every person this isn't complicated
let me tell you if a person has this
medicine and is born is born female they
are a woman that is not a man and the
vast majority of the world considers
that to be a woman because there are
biological differences between men and
women
I mean clearly any high school biology
class teaches that men and women have
different chromosomes females are XX
chromosome and male are X Y chromosome I
can't believe it's necessary to say this
but men cannot get pregnant and cannot
get birth give birth regardless of how
they identify themselves
uh so we we see these exchanges now
every time pretty much anytime there's a
any Hearing in the in the house that we
get we get this question from Republican
lawmaker can men give birth what is a
woman and I think it's great I mean it's
fantastic this is exactly what you
should be doing
um and especially if they're there to
talk about anything related to pregnancy
if they're there to talk about anything
science related
um then yes you should get them on the
record
uh endorsing the idea that men can give
birth so that's that is a this is this
is progress for the Republican party I'm
glad they're doing it uh but you notice
the response there the response was
yes men can give get pregnant
especially trans men especially not only
but especially now a trans man quote
unquote is a woman who identifies as a
man and yes we all know that those
individuals I mean if they haven't uh
mutilated or their body or or sterilize
themselves yet
um they can get pregnant
so we know that yes it's a woman who who
calls herself something else or mentally
identifies another way can still get
pregnant she still has all the functions
of a woman that's our Point that's what
we're saying
that that actually helps us
that yes no matter how you identify
unless you unless you go to a surgeon
and tell them to start removing parts of
your body
doesn't matter if no matter how you
identify your your
biological essence
the biological reality remains
but what about but but especially
so especially means that well in in
particular
uh women who identify as men can get
pregnant
but since you're using the word
especially that would seem to indicate
that even non-trans men can get pregnant
so the claim that we just heard from
that doctor
is that not only women who identify as
men who get pregnant but actual
biological men
can get pregnant
this is what we hear from doctors now
something that we unfortunately again
always have to keep in mind
when you're going to the doctor you're
Consulting any any health care
professional
not saying that you never should I'm not
saying that you should uh
you know swear off modern medicine
entirely that wouldn't be a good idea
for your own health and safety but
you do have to keep in mind that much of
the medical profession is totally
compromised and has been claimed by this
absolute abject insanity
um and has lost its grip on physical
reality so you gotta remember that and
just be cautious and look out for that
a little bit later on AOC chimed in and
had a rebuke for the transphobia that we
just heard there but but something also
to say before that let's listen
briefly I'd like to address some of the
prior claims that uh and prior several
prior immediate claims one being that
abortion is not an economic issue and
that we should be focused on economic
issues and I also you know I think it's
important to state that
um that abortion is an economic issue
forcing poor and working-class people uh
to give birth
um against their will against their
consent
um against their ability to provide for
themselves or a child is a profound
economic issue and it's certainly a way
to keep a Workforce uh
basically conscripted uh to large-scale
employers and two employers to be to
work more against their will to take
second and third jobs against their
desire and their own autonomy and so the
idea that
um that abortion and access to abortion
is somehow not a profound and Central
economic and class issue and class
struggle is certainly something that I
think a person who's never had to
contend uh with the ability to carry a
child
um you know it belies that perspective
um and it's disappointing to see
um but secondly I think another thing
that I'd like to address is that the
same folks who tell who tell us and told
us that clovid kovid's just a flu that
climate change isn't real that January 6
was nothing but a tourist visit are the
same are now trying to tell us that
transgender people are not real
and I would say that their claim is
probably just as legitimate as all their
others which is to say not very much at
all
cheers
so stupid all the time
and it's not it's not a put on it's not
an act I mean some of these people on
the left there are people on the left
are quite intelligent and they're the
ones you have to watch out for the most
uh they're very smart and and um
and scheming and devious and they say
things that they know aren't true
but
I don't think that's true for AOC I
think she actually is
enormously dumb
you know uh that's that's what I think
the issue is for her so when she says
the trans people exist you're denying
the existence of trans people I I I'm
willing to believe that she actually
believes that that's the issue here
but of course it isn't
no one is denying that quote trans
people obviously we know that otherwise
we wouldn't be having this conversation
how can you claim in one in one breath
that were transphobic and the other
breath were denying the existence of
trans people if they don't exist then
there's no so if are we afraid of them
or do we deny they exist because if
before denying that they exist and
there'd be nothing to be afraid of
you got to choose one or the other
now both are not correct but at least
choose one falsehood or the other not
two falsehoods that contradict each
other
people who
identify as trans exist people who make
uh the claim that they are a sex other
than what they were born at Birth exist
those people exist however the claims
they are making about reality are false
that's what we're saying we're denying
their claims
not their physical existence you [ __ ]
what she says before that is even worse
though because she's exactly wrong she's
she is she is she's chosen a position
that is the diametric she's like on the
South Pole and what is and the truth is
the North Pole she's in the she's the
all she couldn't get farther away from
the truth
she says
that it's kind of a conspiracy among
corporations and the wealthy
um to push abortion Bans
you know because it helps their own
bottom line what
what major corporations are supporting
abortion bans
almost every single one of them have
come out and denounced abortion bans and
not only that but a lot of these
corporations are paying
to send their employees to other states
to get abortions
that's what the corporations are doing
you ignoramus
that's what almost all of them are doing
and why would they do that
because it's better for the corporation
that's better for your employer if you
kill your child because then you have
more time to spend at work
it doesn't help how does it help your
job if you have a baby
especially as a woman it means that you
got you have the baby you take maternity
leave
and now you have something else in your
life that is claiming your time and
attention you have something that is
pulling you away from the job especially
as a woman
well the employers they don't want that
the corporations they don't want that so
uh so they're they're going to ship you
off and they'll say sure we'll pay for
your abortion yeah go ahead we'll do
that
means you have more time for us it means
that we as the corporation we Remain the
focus of your life we don't want the
baby to be the focus of your life we
don't want your family to be the focus
of your life we want us we want what
happens here in this building in your in
your dumb little cubicle we want that to
be the thing that's most important to
you
and that's why they pay for the
abortions
so she she literally could not be more
wrong about that that'll do it for this
portion of the show as we move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not talk to you on Monday
happy flannel Friday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]